This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The Sydney Opera House is one of the most iconic and distinctive buildings in the world. It took a relative newcomer and architectural outsider to dream it up. But the saga of making this future world heritage landmark a reality is a tale for the ages, a cautionary tale. And for cautionary tales, I had turned to the brilliant Tim Hartford. I've been dying to hear the story of the Sydney Opera House told in this way, and Tim's walk north of Copenhagen stood a little house.
这是《99%无形》。我是罗曼·马斯。悉尼歌剧院是世界上最具标志性和独特性的建筑之一。它的构思出自一位相对的新人和建筑界的局外人。然而，将这一未来世界文化遗产变为现实的传奇却是一个流传千古的警世故事。对于警世故事，我请教了才华横溢的蒂姆·哈特福德。我一直渴望听到以这种方式讲述的悉尼歌剧院的故事，而蒂姆在哥本哈根以北漫步时，曾矗立着一座小房子。
A fairy tale setting worthy of Hans Christian Andersen perhaps, but this is no fairy tale, and it wasn't a fairy tale house, it was low, flat and minimalist. Denmark's first open plan house. It had been built in 1952, without proper floor plans. The house's young architect was building his own home and hid insisted instead on personally directing the work as it progressed. But it was brilliant. Denmark's most celebrated architect visited the construction site and muttered under his breath, hell, he's better than I am. Maybe so. It was hard to be sure. The young architect, Yorne Utsen, had won plenty of competitions, but with his career interrupted
这或许是一个配得上汉斯·克里斯蒂安·安徒生的童话背景，但这并非童话，那也不是一座童话般的房子，它低矮、平坦而极简。这是丹麦第一座开放式住宅。它建于 1952 年，没有完整的平面图。这位年轻的建筑师在建造自己的家时，坚持在施工过程中亲自进行现场指导。但它确实才华横溢。丹麦最著名的建筑师参观了施工现场，喃喃自语道：见鬼，他比我还厉害。也许吧。这很难确定。这位年轻的建筑师约恩·乌松赢得了许多设计竞赛，但由于他的职业生涯因
by the war, that house was almost the only thing he had actually built. Late in January 1957, the phone in the Utsun home rang. Yorne and his wife were taking a winter walk in the woods. Their ten-year-old daughter, Lynn, was at home babysitting her new born brother. She answered the phone. Hello. The village operator was on the other end.
战争而中断，那座房子几乎是他实际建造的唯一东西。1957 年 1 月下旬，乌松家里的电话铃响了。约恩和妻子正在树林里进行冬日漫步。他们十岁的女儿琳正在家照顾刚出生的弟弟。她接了电话。喂。电话那头是村里的接线员。
She knew the family. Lynn, is your father home? No. Is your mother home? No, they're out walking. Quick, go find your father. He's one of prize. It's someone from the newspaper in Sydney, Australia.
她认识这家人。琳，你爸爸在家吗？不在。你妈妈在家吗？不在，他们出去散步了。快去找到你爸爸。他得奖了。那是澳大利亚悉尼一家报社打来的。
Go turn to come quick. Lin drops the phone, leaves her sleeping brother and grabs her bike. She races out into the Danish winter, yelling for her parents. He must have been alarmed to see their little blonde baby sitting daughter cycling towards them, screaming at the top of her voice. Sydney, Sydney. She skids to a halt. You want a prize?
快去把人找回来。琳放下电话，撇下正在睡觉的弟弟，抓起自行车。她冲进丹麦的冬日里，大声呼喊着父母。看到他们金发碧眼的宝贝女儿一边骑车向他们冲来，一边扯着嗓子尖叫，他们一定感到很惊慌。悉尼，悉尼。她一个急刹车停了下来。你得奖了？
You want something in Sydney? Someone's on the phone and they want to talk to you. It must have felt like a phone call from the moon. The unknown young Dane, Yorne Utson, had won an international competition to design the Sydney Opera House. But Utson couldn't have imagined what a bitter victory it would prove to be. I'm Tim Halford, and you're listening to Corsion Retails. Music Eugene Goussens was a distinguished violinist and conductor. In the 1940s he moved from
你在悉尼得了什么奖吗？有人打来电话，想和你谈谈。这感觉一定像是来自月球的电话。这位名不见经传的年轻丹麦人约恩·乌松赢得了设计悉尼歌剧院的国际竞赛。但乌松不可能料到，这将是一场多么痛苦的胜利。我是蒂姆·哈特福德，你收听的是《警世故事》。音乐尤金·古森斯是一位杰出的中小提琴家和指挥家。20 世纪 40 年代，他从
Britain to the faraway city of Sydney, where he was struck by three things. The beauty of the harbour, the apparent indifference of the locals to that beauty, and the lack of a really good venue for classical music. Goosons dreamed up an idea, build a huge opera house on Benelong Point, a finger of rock poking out into Sydney's glorious harbour in which blue water is surrounded on all sides by the city, and spanned by the vast arch of the Sydney Harbour Bridge. Goosens was charismatic and local politicians were keen to show that they could deliver cultural amenities for Sydney voters. They formed a committee which announced an open competition to design the new opera
英国搬到了遥远的悉尼市，在那里他被三件事深深震撼：海港的美丽、当地人对这种美丽似乎漠不关心的态度，以及缺乏一个真正适合举办古典音乐的高水平场馆。古森斯萌生了一个想法：在贝尼朗岬角建造一座巨大的歌剧院。贝尼朗岬角是一块伸入悉尼壮丽海港的岩石半岛，海港碧水环绕，四周是城市，宏伟的悉尼海港大桥跨海而过。古森斯极具个人魅力，当地政客也急于向悉尼选民展示他们能够提供文化设施。他们成立了一个委员会，宣布举行公开竞赛来设计新的歌剧
house. Anyone, even an unknown young architect from Denmark, could try to win. As Goosen's grand project gathered momentum, he flew back to London to be knighted by the queen. And on his return, tipped off by a journalist, customs officers asked to search his luggage. They found it to be packed with naughty photographs and even naughtier rubber masks. In 1950s Australia, it was a scandal. Sir Eugene fled back to London, a broken man. Alas, Sir Eugene's fate, great talent, self-inflicted wounds and a tragic end to a great career
院。任何人，甚至是来自丹麦的不知名年轻建筑师，都可以尝试去赢得比赛。随着古森斯的宏伟项目逐渐推进，他飞回伦敦接受女王的册封。而在他回国时，海关官员在记者的通风报信下，要求搜查他的行李。他们发现里面塞满了色情照片，甚至还有更加出格的橡胶面具。在 20 世纪 50 年代的澳大利亚，这是一桩丑闻。尤金爵士狼狈逃回伦敦，成了一个心碎的人。唉，尤金爵士的命运——伟大的才华、自作自受的创伤以及一段伟大职业生涯的悲惨结局——
is just the overture to the story of the Sydney Opera House, in which the same dramatic beats would play out on a much bigger stage. Not that anyone should have expected the Sydney Opera House to be an easy project. So Eugene had wanted big concert halls, but Ben Along Point was a cramped site. The premiere of the state wanted a grand legacy, a building for the ages, but no politician wanted to raise taxes to pay for it. And Opera House's have actually rather ungainly structures, they're bulging towers for stage machinery, they're usually hidden behind grand facades. But Sydney's
这只是悉尼歌剧院故事的序曲，同样的戏剧性桥段将在一个更大的舞台上重演。并不是说任何人会指望悉尼歌剧院是一个轻松的项目。尤金爵士曾希望拥有大型音乐厅，但贝尼朗岬角是一个空间逼仄的场址。时任州长想要留下宏伟的遗产，一座跨时代的建筑，但没有任何政客愿意通过加税来为之买单。而且歌剧院实际上是结构相当笨拙的建筑，它们是用于舞台机械的隆起塔楼，通常隐藏在宏伟的立面背后。但悉尼的
opera house couldn't hide, it would be visible across the water, from north, east and west, even from above, from the monumental Sydney Harbour Bridge. In announcing their competition then, the committee laid down the challenge to architects from around the world. Design an opera house for us. It needs to be huge, fit onto a tiny site, look amazing from any angle, and be cheap. Knock yourselves out. In January 1957, the time came to choose a winner. The judging panel spent four days sifting through more than 200 entries and drawing up a shortlist.
歌剧院却无处可藏，从北、东、西各个方向的远方水面上都能看到它，甚至从宏伟的悉尼海港大桥上方俯瞰也能看到。因此，委员会在宣布竞赛时，向全世界的建筑师提出了挑战。为我们设计一座歌剧院。它必须体量巨大，建在一个极小的地块上，从任何角度看都必须惊艳，而且还要便宜。大展身手吧。1957 年 1 月，挑选获胜者的时刻到了。评判团花了四天时间从 200 多个参赛作品中筛选并拟定了一份入围名单。
They were waiting for the arrival of the final judge, an architectural rock star, the great Finnish American architect, Eero Saranon, but he was running late. That was understandable. Saranon was a busy man, designer of landmarks such as the celebrated TWA terminal at New York's International Airport. And if buildings like that helped New York to feel like the center of the world, then Sydney, at the world's edge, wanted some of that stardust.
他们正在等待最后一位评委的到来——一位建筑界的摇滚巨星、伟大的芬兰裔美国建筑师埃罗·沙里宁，但他迟到了。这也可以理解。沙里宁是个大忙人，他是纽约国际机场著名的环球航空公司航站楼等标志性建筑的设计师。如果像这样的建筑能让纽约感受到自己是世界的中心，那么处于世界边缘的悉尼也渴望沾染一些这种星光。
When the other judges showed Erosarinen the 10 leading entries, everyone could tell that he wasn't impressed. The ideas were awkward compromises, predictably boxed in by their attempts to satisfy the contradictory requirements of the competition. Sounan shook his head and went for a stroll to Ben Along Point. He sat and sketched for a while. Correst on three sides by the lapping waters of Sydney Harbor, it really was a magnificent spot.
当其他评委向埃罗·沙里宁展示了 10 个领先的参赛作品时，每个人都能看出他并不为所动。这些构想都是些尴尬的妥协方案，正如预料的那样，由于试图满足竞赛中相互矛盾的要求，它们的思路受到了局限。沙里宁摇了摇头，去贝尼朗岬角散步了。他坐下来画了一会儿草图。三面环绕着悉尼港轻拍的波浪，这里确实是一个绝佳的地点。
He returned to the judging room and started flipping through the rejects. There was one which stood out as completely different, even though it was really little more than a sketch. There was a monumental base, reminiscent of an Aztec pyramid or a Chinese imperial palace. Floating above it were light, shell-like roof structures, overlapping like the sails of some grand ship.
他回到评审室，开始翻看那些被淘汰的作品。其中有一个作品脱颖而出，显得完全不同，尽管它实际上只是一张草图。那里有一个宏伟的基座，让人想起阿兹特克金字塔或中国皇宫。漂浮在它上方的是轻盈的、贝壳状的屋顶结构，像一艘宏伟巨轮的风帆一样相互交叠。
It was like no building Sarenan had ever seen. He laid it out, stepped back to ponder it, stepped forward to peer at the details. Then he turned to the other judges. Gentlemen, here is your opera house. Twelve days later, the state premier Joseph K. Hill stands in front of the cameras with a sealed envelope. He's a former trade union organizer, not your stereotypical opera-gour, but now that the disgraced Sir Eugene Goosens has fled the country, K-Hill has surprised some people by stepping up
这就像沙里宁见过的任何建筑都不同。他把它平铺开来，退后几步沉思，又走上前去仔细端详细节。然后他转向其他评委。先生们，这就是你们的歌剧院。十二天后，州长约瑟夫·卡希尔站在镜头前，手里拿着一个封好的信封。他曾是一名工会组织者，并非那种传统的歌剧爱好者，但现在声名狼藉的尤金爵士已经逃离了国家，卡希尔挺身而出，成为歌剧院最坚定的支持者，这让一些人感到意外。
as the opera-house's biggest champion. Like any good politician, he's going to milk this dramatic moment. The winning design, he announces, is scheme number 218. And who designed that? K-hill doesn't have the name to hand. An official hurries forward, rummages in the envelope, pulls out a second document. I.S. A Scheme number, 218, submitted by… Um…
像任何优秀的政治家一样，他要充分利用这个戏剧性的时刻。他宣布，获胜的设计是第 218 号方案。是谁设计的？卡希尔手头没有名字。一名官员急忙走上前，在信封里摸索，掏出了第二份文件。呃……这是一个方案，第 218 号，由……呃……提交。
Yorn Utsun of Hellebeck, Denmark. Yorn Utsun? Who? A reporter from the Sydney Morning Herald places a long distance call to directory assistance in Hellebeck. They try Utsun's directory assistance in Hellerbake. They try Utsun's office number. He's not there. Then they try his home number.
丹麦赫勒贝克的约恩·乌松。约恩·乌松？谁？《悉尼先驱晨报》的一名记者给赫勒贝克的查号台打了个长途电话。他们试着拨打乌松在赫勒贝克的查号台电话。他们试拨了乌松办公室的号码。他不在。然后他们试拨了他家的号码。
The operator comes back on the line. Apparently, he's gone out for a walk, but his daughter has gone to find him. Is it okay to hold? For the first interview with the unknown winner of the Sydney Opera House competition, sure, he'll hold all of Australia wants to know about the mysterious Yorn Utsum. When the winning sketch was published, public opinion was divided. Letters published in the Sydney Morning Herald describe the designers a wonderful piece of sculpture, a haystack covered by several tapalins, a ray of hope, a sink with plates stacked in readiness for washing, some large
接线员重新上线。显然，他出去散步了，但他的女儿已经去找他了。请在线稍候可以吗？对于悉尼歌剧院竞赛这位神秘赢家的首次采访，当然，他愿意等待，全澳大利亚都想了解神秘的约恩·乌松。当获奖草图公开发布时，公众舆论意见不一。《悉尼先驱晨报》上发表的读者来信将这些设计描述为一件精美的雕塑、一堆盖着几块防水布的干草堆、一丝希望、一个堆满待洗盘子的水槽、某个想象中的宏伟可爱巨轮、一个无法折叠收纳的丑陋降落伞。但当约恩·乌松抵达悉尼时，其中一些疑虑开始消融。
lovely ship of the imagination, a hideous parachute which we cannot fold up and put away. But when your Nutson arrived in Sydney, some of those doubts began to melt away. Tall, blonde, blue-eyed, that sexy Danish accent, movie star looks. He's our Gary Cooper, declared one local lady. Sydney was a bustling place, but it usually felt far from the world spotlight. Now, it felt as though Hollywood had come to call, the city fell in love with the man.
高大、金发、蓝眼睛、性感迷人的丹麦口音、电影明星般的长相。他就是我们的加里·库珀，一位当地女士宣称。悉尼曾是一个繁忙的地方，但它通常远离世界的聚光灯。现在，感觉就像好莱坞来访一样，整座城市都爱上了这个男人。
Professional architects were more cautious. The sketches were impressive, sure, but Hudson hadn't submitted all the plans and drawings the competition rules specified. One Australian art critic described his entry as nothing more than a magnificent doodle. What's more, Hudson's doodle building overstepped the site's boundaries. Then there was the question of whether its glorious sale-like roof structures could actually stand up.
专业建筑师则更为谨慎。这些草图确实令人印象深刻，但乌松并未提交竞赛规则所规定的所有平面图和图纸。一位澳大利亚艺术评论家甚至将他的参赛作品形容涂鸦。不仅如此，乌松的涂鸦建筑超出了地块的边界。此外，其光彩夺目的帆状屋顶结构究竟能否真正支撑起来，也是个问题。
None of this worried Eero Sarenan, the rock star architect, who'd pushed his fellow judges into choosing Utson's entry. Nothing to it said Sarenan about those roof structures. Three inches thick at the top and say, 12 inches thick at the base. But concrete shell architecture was still an emerging field. Many experts weren't so sure. Yes, egg shell structures could be surprisingly strong, but cut the egg in half and much of that strength is gone.
这一切都没有困扰摇滚巨星建筑师埃罗·沙里宁，正是他力促同僚评委们选择了乌松的作品。沙里宁谈到那些屋顶结构时说，这没什么大不了的。顶部厚三英寸，底部厚十二英寸左右。但混凝土薄壳建筑当时仍是一个新兴领域。许多专家并没有那么大把握。是的，蛋壳结构可以具有惊人的强度，但如果把鸡蛋切成两半，大部分强度就消失了。
And Buttson's opera house roof, it was a series of quarter shells. Until this point Buttson had taken no engineering advice. And he wouldn't have long to figure out a solution because the project's champion, State Premier Joseph K. Hill, was a man in a hurry. He was a heavy smoker with a history of health problems. He knew he was also at risk of losing the next election. He wanted a monument to his place in history. So he instructed the Opera House team. Go down to Benelong Point and make such progress that no one who succeeds me can stop this going through the completion.
而乌松歌剧院的屋顶是一系列四分之一的贝壳状结构。在此之前，乌松没有咨询过任何工程方面的意见。而且他也没有多少时间来找出解决方案，因为该项目标支持者、州长约瑟夫·卡希尔是一个急性子。他是个老烟民，有健康问题史。他知道自己也面临着在下次选举中失利的风险。他想要一座能证明自己在历史地位上的纪念碑。因此，他向歌剧院团队指示：去贝尼朗岬角大刀阔斧地推进工程，让任何在我之后继任的人都无法阻止这个项目完工。
As a result, the building started before Buttson could figure out the structural basics. Joseph K. Hill laid the foundation stone on the 2nd of March 1959. Within a year, he was dead, killed by his third heart attack. But just as he'd intended, so much work had already been done that stopping the project was unthinkable. By now, an engineer had been found. His name was Over-Arupp, the Anglo-Danish boss of Over Arup and Partners, a respected engineering firm. The two Danes, Utsun and Arup, had been working together to try to figure out a solution to the structural problem. And it was at this point that Arup informed Utsun of the bad news. His beautiful, free-standing roof shells simply couldn't be built.
结果，在乌松弄清楚结构基础之前，建筑工程就已经开始了。1959 年 3 月 2 日，约瑟夫·卡希尔奠定了基石。一年内，他就去世了，死于第三次心脏病发作。但正如他所愿，当时已有太多工作完成，叫停这个项目已是不可想象的事。此时，人们已经找到了一位工程师。他的名字叫奥韦·阿鲁普，是备受尊敬的工程公司“奥韦·阿鲁普合伙人公司”的英籍丹麦裔老板。两位丹麦人乌松和阿鲁普一直在合作试图找出解决结构问题的方案。正是在这个时候，阿鲁普将这个坏消息告诉了乌松：他那美观的、独立的屋顶壳体根本无法建造。
There's no such thing as too many daines, so let's meet a third. Bent Flubia. He's the world's leading expert on large projects, and on why these mega projects are so often delivered late and way over budget. And he's fascinated by the Sydney Opera House because it's the ultimate case study, the definitive fiasco of how not to run a mega project. Flubio says that the original scene of many mega projects is this. People start building before they figure out what they're really trying to do. The ideal mega project starts with a question, why are we doing this? Then there's a long, careful planning process.
世上没有太多的丹麦人，所以让我们来认识第三位：本特·弗利维伯格。他是大型项目以及这些特大型项目为何总是延期且严重超预算的世界顶级专家。他之所以对悉尼歌剧院着迷，是因为它是终极案例研究，是运作特大型项目的绝对反面教材。弗利维伯格表示，许多特大型项目的最初症结在于：人们在弄清楚自己究竟想做什么之前就已经开始建设了。理想的特大型项目始于一个问题：我们为什么要这样做？然后是一个漫长而谨慎的规划过程。
Every detail is finalised, then the expensive construction phase can be kept as short as possible, with no costly changes. The opera house violated these principles in the most flagrant way imaginable. Nobody ever really answered the question. Why? So Eugene Gussens had wanted to accommodate a lot of opera garrers and use the beautiful location of Ben Long Point. The state's premier, Joseph K. Hill, had wanted a lasting monument on the cheap, without
每一个细节都被敲定，然后昂贵的施工阶段就可以尽可能缩短，避免代价高昂的变更。歌剧院以最公然、最不可想象的方式违背了这些原则。从来没有人真正回答过这个问题：为什么？尤金·古森斯曾希望容纳大量的歌剧观众，并利用贝尼朗岬角的美丽位置。州长约瑟夫·卡希尔则希望以低成本留下一个持久的纪念碑，而无需花费纳税人的钱。约恩·乌松想要建造一些美丽而崭新的东西。但如果你无法让它既美观又便宜呢？如果你无法在把它塞进贝尼朗岬角的同时做到体量宏大呢？
spending tax pay or money. Yorne Utson wanted to build something beautiful and new. But what if you couldn't make it both beautiful and cheap? What if you couldn't make it big while also squeezing it onto Ben Long Point? The trade-offs were swept under the carpet, the difficult decisions postponed or ignored. Then of course, the building was rushed, with workers digging foundations before Utsun and Arup had figured out how to build the thing. Utsun was in an impossible position.
种种权衡利弊被扫到地毯下，艰难的决定被推迟或忽视。当然，接着就是仓促施工，工人们在乌松和阿鲁普还没弄清楚如何建造这东西之前就开始挖掘地基了。乌松处于一个不可能的境地。
And Utsun wasn't blaneless either. Remember how he'd never drawn proper plans for his beautiful home in the Danish forest, but instead had been on site throughout, personally directing the builders. Careful planning was all very well, but he loved to experiment, to feel his way through a project. It worked for his beautiful home, but could it also work for a colossal structurally innovative mega-project. Utsun worked like an artist, not a project manager. He wanted to make the final decision on every detail, no matter how small. At one point, he declared about a particular design change.
而且乌松也并非无可指责。还记得他当年在丹麦森林里为自己美丽的家没有画出合适的图纸，而是一直留在现场亲自指导建筑工人吗？仔细规划固然很好，但他喜欢实验，喜欢在项目中摸索前行。这对他那美丽的家很管用，但对一个庞大且结构创新的特大型项目也管用吗？乌松的工作方式像个艺术家，而不是项目经理。他想对每一个细节做出最终决定，无论多小。有一次，针对某个特定的设计变更，他宣称：
I don't care what it costs. I don't care what scandal it causes. I don't care how long it takes. That's what I want. That attitude explains why Utsun's opera house is the most beautiful building in the world. It also made him the mother of all bottlenecks, especially as Utsun had a habit of disappearing for weeks at a time. After his second visit to Sydney, Utsun decided to
我不在乎花多少钱。我不在乎引起什么丑闻。我不在乎花多长时间。这就是我想要的。这种态度解释了为什么乌松的歌剧院是世界上最美丽的建筑。这也让他成为了所有瓶颈的始作俑者，尤其是乌松还有动辄失踪数周的习惯。在第二次访问悉尼后，乌松决定经由中国、日本和尼泊尔返回丹麦。当他终于再次露面时，阿鲁普半开玩笑地写道：很高兴听到你的消息。我还以为你在亚洲的荒野中迷路了呢。
return to Denmark via China, Japan and Nepal. When he finally resurfaced, Arup Jovially wrote, It was nice to hear from you. I really thought you were lost in the wilds of Asia. Utsun had hoped to pick up inspiration on his travels that he could use for the opera house, and he did. But decisions on the project ground to a halt without him. And the problem of the roof was no joke. Sons' original magnificent doodle used a variety of different curves. That caused two headaches. The first was the expense. It made every section of the roof a unique construction. The second was more serious. Arupp had to spend a fortune on ground
乌松本希望在旅行中获得可以用于歌剧院的灵感，他也确实做到了。但如果没有他，项目的决策陷入了停滞。而且屋顶的问题绝非开玩笑。乌松最初那宏伟的涂鸦使用了各种不同的曲线。这带来了两个头痛的问题。首先是费用。这使得屋顶的每个部分都成为独特的建筑。第二个更为严重。阿鲁普不得不花一大笔钱进行突破性的计算机模拟，以弄清楚它们是否会在自身重量下坍塌。最终，阿鲁普得出结论：它们会的。
breaking computer simulations to figure out whether they would collapse under their own weight. Eventually Arupp concluded that they would. It was Utson who solved the problem. In a flash of inspiration, he realized that each part of each vaulted roof, large or small, could be proportioned as though it was sliced out of the same single, enormous sphere. doesn't sound like much, but the structural properties of these spherical curves were well understood. And because the curves would all be identical,
正是乌松解决了这个问题。灵光一现之际，他意识到每个拱形屋顶的每个部分，无论大小，都可以按比例设计，就好像它们是从同一个巨大的单一部件中切出来的一样。这听起来可能没什么，但这些球形曲线的结构特性是人们所熟知的。而且因为这些曲线将完全相同，它们的建造成本可以大大降低。
they could be built at much lower cost. Butson was delighted. It was the cheapest way of making it you could dream of. All the work during these three years has been the background for arriving at this magnificent solution. If they hadn't yet started construction, this would have been a triumphant moment. Unfortunately, construction had begun two and a half years earlier. The new design would require heavier supports than the ones they had just built, and the ones they had just built were almost indestructible.
乌松欣喜若狂。这是你能梦想到的最便宜的制造方式。这三年来的所有工作都是得出这个宏伟解决方案的背景。如果他们还没有开始施工，这将是一个值得欢呼的时刻。不幸的是，施工已经在两年半前开始了。新设计需要比他们刚刚建造的更重的支撑，而他们刚刚建造的支撑几乎是不可摧毁的。
The local contractor recommended dynamiting them, one by one, during the rush hour, so that the noise would be camouflaged by the traffic. That worked for a while until a lump of concrete was blown high over the harbor and landed on a passing ferry. Another opera house bungle yelled the local newspapers. Utson had decided to move his office to Sydney to oversee proceedings. That was a good idea, thought Arup's team, until Utsun told them he'd be travelling again, and out of contact between Christmas and March. Arup begged him not to do this.
当地承包商建议在交通高峰期用炸药将它们逐一炸毁，这样噪音就会被交通噪音掩盖。这招管用了一段时间，直到一块混凝土被炸到海港高空，落在一艘路过的渡轮上。当地报纸大喊：又一起歌剧院的彻底失败。乌松决定将办公室搬到悉尼以监督各项事宜。阿鲁普的团队认为这主意不错，直到乌松告诉他们，他又得去旅行了，而且在圣诞节到三月期间将无法取得联系。阿鲁普恳求他不要这样做。
There were so many decisions to be made, and Utsun was the only person who could make them. But Utsun agreed only to a long meeting near London's Heathrow Airport, the day after Christmas, to pin down a long list of details. Utsun was persuaded to hurry the very last mile of his journey. While flying from Tahiti to Sydney, the DC-7 airliner's radio crackled into life with an invitation. Her majesty, the Queen, was on the Royal Yacht in Sydney Harbour, and Mr. Wutzen was invited to lunch. After touchdown, he dashed to the Royal Reception. Arupp's man on the ground wasn't impressed. Lo and behold, God appears from heaven.
有那么多决定需要做出，而乌松是唯一能做决定的人。但乌松只同意在圣诞节的第二天，在伦敦希思罗机场附近开一次漫大会议，以敲定长长的一单细节。乌松被说服在行程的最后几英里加速赶路。当从大溪地飞往悉尼时，DC-7 客机的无线电发出了一份邀请。女王陛下当时正在悉尼港的皇家游艇上，乌松先生被邀请共进午餐。飞机降落后，他冲向皇家招待会。阿鲁普在现场的人员对此并不买账。看吧，上帝从天而降。
Utson had descended from Tahiti, popped in for lunch with the Queen, and then grumbled the Arupp engineer. And the afternoon he comes onto the site and starts complaining about some things he wasn't informed about. I mean there was no one we could contact. Four months later, July 1963, the Opera House was scheduled to have been finished. Yet the site on Ben Along Point was still just a huge flat sprawl of concrete.
乌松从大溪地降落，顺道和女王吃了顿午餐，阿鲁普的工程师抱怨道。下午他来到现场，开始对一些他根本不知情的事情抱怨。我的意思是，根本没有人能联系到他。四个月后，即 1963 年 7 月，歌剧院本该完工。然而，贝尼朗岬角上的工地依然只是一片巨大的、平坦的混凝土摊开地。
The basic outline of the broad, low podium was visible with the structure of the two sunken theatres scooped out of it. There was no sign of walls, let alone the roof. In his history of the project, the saga of Sydney Opera House, architectural writer Peter Murray, combs through the letters between Uva, Arup and Yorne, Utsun, and finds two men whose relationship is slowly falling apart. Utsun worried that Arup was trying to take control and steal the credit. Arup was eyeing the exits.
宽阔而低矮的裙楼的基本轮廓依稀可见，两个下沉式剧院的结构从其中挖空。根本看不到墙壁的踪迹，更不用说屋顶了。建筑作家彼得·默里在其关于该项目历史的书籍《悉尼歌剧院传奇》中，梳理了奥韦·阿鲁普和约恩·乌松之间的信件，发现这两个人的关系正在慢慢破裂。乌松担心阿鲁普试图夺取控制权并窃取功劳。阿鲁普则在密切关注退路。
Here's Arup. I do not know whether you have thought of getting other engineers to help you. I would welcome the idea of someone else solving the problems and experiencing your method of working. Butsen responded, dear uva, please dissist from your criticism. Management is in a way the easiest part of the job, something which most people can learn. Well, perhaps. Nobody doubted Utsun's genius as an architect, but as deadline after deadline was being broken, this was no time to be taking management for granted. The mega-project expert, Bent Flubia, argues that the longer the construction phase of
这是阿鲁普的信：我不知道你是否考虑过找其他工程师来帮忙。我很欢迎其他人来解决问题并体验你的工作方法。乌松回应道：亲爱的奥韦，请停止你的批评。管理在某种程度上是工作中最简单的一部分，是大多数人都能学会的。好吧，也许吧。没有人怀疑乌松作为建筑师的天才，但随着一个又一个截止日期被打破，现在可不是把管理视为理所当然的时候。特大型项目专家本特·弗利维伯格争辩说，一个项目的施工阶段持续时间越长，发生某些事情导致一切脱轨的时间就越多。
a project lasts, the more time there is for something to derail everything. He's right. In May 1965, two years after the opera house was supposed to have been finished, there was a state election in New South Wales. The backdrop for this election was an expensive and manifestly unfinished building. The roofshelves had at last been built, finished building. The roofshelves had at last been built, soaring above the podium and the waters of the harbour, but they were bare concrete. The epic job of tiling them had hardly begun. The site was open to the elements, since the spectacular glass curtain wall facing out over the harbour was still just a structural problem on Utsun's drawing board. And so, the populist opposition party campaigned on a promise to clean up the mess
他是对的。1965 年 5 月，也就是歌剧院本该完工两年后，新南威尔士州举行了州选举。这场选举的背景是一个昂贵且明显尚未完工的建筑。屋顶壳体终于建好了，高高耸立在裙楼和海港水面上，但它们只是光秃秃的混凝土。为它们贴瓷砖的史诗般的工作才刚刚开始。工地暴露在风雨中，因为面向海港的壮观玻璃幕墙在乌松的图纸上仍然只是一个结构问题。于是，民粹主义反对党发起竞选活动，承诺要收拾歌剧院的烂摊子。
at the opera house. Although the project was funded mostly by proceeds from the state lottery, rather than taxes, it was hugely over budget. And conservative rural voters had started to wonder why that lottery money couldn't be spent on something else, such as more, roads, schools and hospitals. When the opposition won, the job of Minister for Public Works went to a politician named Davis Hughes. Hughes was a controversial choice, and not
尽管该项目主要由州彩票收入而非税收资助，但它严重超预算。保守的农村选民开始纳闷，为什么彩票的钱不能花在其他地方，比如更多的道路、学校和医院。当反对党获胜时，公共工程部长的职位落到了一位名叫戴维斯·休斯的政客手中。休斯是一个颇具争议的选择，不仅因为他最近因在求职申请中虚假声称拥有学士学位而臭名昭著。当他被委任负责这个庞大的建筑项目时，他的妻子笑着评论说，他连一颗钉子都钉不直。
only because he'd recently become notorious for falsely claiming to have a bachelor's degree in job applications. When he was put in charge of this vast construction project, his wife laughingly remarked that he couldn't drive a nail in straight. In the first six months of his tenure, Hughes struggled to get a grip, to his frustration, spending on the opera house ballooned more than ever. By the start of 1966, nine years after Utsun had become famous around the world for winning the design competition, Hughes was ready for a showdown. He began withholding payments to Utsun, demanding more oversight
在上任的前六个月里，休斯艰难地试图掌控局面，令他沮丧的是，歌剧院的花费比以往任何时候都更加膨胀。到 1966 年初，也就是乌松因赢得设计竞赛而闻名世界九年后，休斯已经准备好摊牌了。他开始扣留对乌松的付款，要求更多的监督和更多的控制。没有钱，乌松就无法支付员工的工资。他已经陷入了财务困境，因为丹麦和澳大利亚都在争论他应该向谁纳税。戴维斯·休斯是否在蓄意破坏乌松，还是说他在强加一些急需的纪律？
and more control. Without the money, Utsun couldn't pay his staff. He was already in financial trouble because both Denmark and Australia were arguing that he should be paying his taxes to them. Was Davis Hughes deliberately undermining Utson, or was he imposing some much-needed discipline? Whatever the aim, the result was predictable. However, Arup could see what was coming. He wrote to Utson urging him not to resign, telling him that resigning would solve nothing. But Arab's letter didn't arrive in time to warn
无论目的是什么，结果都是可以预料的。然而，阿鲁普能看出接下来会发生什么。他写信敦促乌松不要辞职，告诉他辞职解决不了任何问题。但阿鲁普的信没有及时送到，没能警告乌松对自己的言论多加小心。在与休斯进行了一场紧张的会面后，乌松发了一封信解释说：通过切断资金，你已经迫使我离开了这份工作。乌松后来表示，他只是因为缺乏资金而暂停工作，辞职从来不是他的意图。但戴维斯·休斯没有看到任何模棱两可的地方。他立即向州议会宣布，约恩·乌松已经辞职。
Utsun to be careful what he said. After a tense meeting with Hughes, Utsun sent a letter explaining that, by cutting off the money, you have forced me to leave the job. Hudson later said that he was just pausing work for lack of funds, and that quitting was never his intention. But Davis Hughes didn't see any ambiguity. He promptly announced to the State Assembly that Yorne Utson had resigned. Utson's departure was announced on the 1st of March 1966, almost exactly seven years after construction had begun.
乌松的离职于 1966 年 3 月 1 日宣布，几乎正好是施工开始七年后。尽管该项目历经波折，但这仍然是一个重磅炸弹。此时，曲线形的贝壳屋顶已经几乎完全贴好了瓷砖。那种微光闪烁的效果看起来蔚为壮观。抗议者聚集在贝尼朗岬角尚未完工的建筑旁，挥舞着标语：“拯救歌剧院”和“我们需要乌松”。澳大利亚皇家建筑师学会告诉戴维斯·休斯：把他请回来。在乌松痛苦离职后，没有哪位知名建筑师肯碰歌剧院项目。这是一个职业声援的问题。
Despite all the project's troubles, it was a bombshell. By now, the curved shells were almost fully tiled. The shimmering effect looked spectacular. Protesters gathered at the half-finished structure on Benelong Point, waving signs, saved the opera house, and we need Utsun. The Royal Australian Institute of Architects told Davis Hughes, get him back. No prominent architect would touch the Opera House project after Utsun's acrimonious departure. It was a matter of professional solidarity.
工程师奥韦·阿鲁普没有辞职。乌松认为这是背叛。他不再接听阿鲁普的电话。阿鲁普亲手写了一封情感真挚的信给乌松，敦促他回来，并主动提出从中调解，与戴维斯·休斯达成妥协。奥韦和约恩难道不能至少见面聊聊吗？他在信尾署名。即使你不信任我，这也毫无害处，不是吗？情况不可能变得更糟了，所以为什么不试试呢？
The engineer, Over Adop, did not resign. Utsun saw this as a betrayal. He stopped returning Arab's calls. Adop hand-wrote an emotional letter to Utsun, urging him to come back and offering to broker a compromise with Davis Hughes. Couldn't over and yawn at least meet for a chat? He signed off. Even if you don't trust me, it couldn't do any harm, could it? The situation can't get
乌松当天就回信了。如果你认为我应该负责这个项目，那就照此行事，他写道，告诉部长乌松必须负责。乌松回到了丹麦，脑子里依然想着项目中所有遗留的挑战，比如如何在音乐厅里塞进更多的座位。他预计戴维斯·休斯会灰溜溜地求他回来，部分原因是他无法想象还有谁有能力完成这项工作。
any worse, so why not try? Butsen replied the same day. If you think I should be in charge of the project, then act accordingly, he wrote, it tell the minister that Utsun should be in charge of the project, then act accordingly," he wrote, it tells the minister that Utsun must be in charge. Utsun returned to Denmark, still thinking about all the remaining challenges on the project, such as how to fit more seats into the hall. He expected that Davis Hughes would come crawling back, in part, because he couldn't imagine anyone else being capable of finishing the job.
我还随时待命。制造所有这些巨大困难的不是我，而是悉尼歌剧院。但戴维斯·休斯并不是那种会退缩的人。如果没有知名建筑师愿意接手这项工作，他就只能找一个默默无闻的人。他找来了当地政府的一位年轻建筑师彼得·霍尔，将完成歌剧院的任务交给了他。霍尔完成了，但这多花了七年时间，并且花费了已经支出资金的三倍。歌剧院的花费是最初预算的 15 倍，不可否认最初的预算本来就是个虚数，而且它的竣工比原计划推迟了整整十年。
I am still available. It is not I, but the Sydney Opera House that creates all of the enormous difficulties. But Davis Hughes wasn't the type to back down. If no prominent architect would take the job, he it just have to get one nobody had heard of. He called in a young local government architect named Peter Hall, and handed him the task of finishing the opera house. Hall did so, taking seven more years, and three times as much money as had already been spent. The Opera House cost 15 times the original budget, admittedly the original budget was always a fiction, and it was completed a decade behind schedule.
约恩·乌松也不是那种会退缩的人。多年后，奥韦·阿鲁普请一位共同的朋友帮忙安排一次和解。也许他和乌松可以见面谈谈。他们开车去了乌松的家乡，阿鲁普坐在酒店大堂里，喝着咖啡等待。朋友回来了。乌松不想见阿鲁普。不会有任何和解。1973 年 10 月 20 日，悉尼歌剧院由伊丽莎白二世女王正式揭幕。约恩·乌松拒绝了出席邀请，这或许也是件好事。女王由当地政客撰写的演讲稿中甚至没有提到乌松的名字。
Your Notson wasn't the type to back down either. Years later, over Arab asked a mutual friend to try to arrange a reconciliation. Maybe he and Utsun could meet and talk things over. They drove to Utsun's hometown, and Arab sat in a hotel lobby, nursing a coffee and waiting. The friend returned. coffee and waiting. The friend returned. Utsun didn't want to see Arup. There would be no reconciliation. The Opera House was officially opened by Queen Elizabeth II on the 20th of October 1973. Yorne Utson declined his invitation to attend, which was perhaps just as well. The Queen's speech written by local politicians didn't mention Utson's name.
她揭幕的牌匾上庆祝的是年轻的彼得·霍尔和戴维斯·休斯。本特·弗利维伯格在他的著作《宏大项目如何完成》中，描述了当明星建筑师弗兰克·盖里被邀请到毕尔巴鄂参与一个建筑项目时发生了什么。与年轻且默默无闻的乌松不同，盖里当时已经 62 岁，在经历了关于其建筑的一些痛苦的政治斗争后身经百战，且名声大噪。毕尔巴鄂的官员向他展示了一座美丽的老仓库，并问他是否考虑将其改造成新的古根海姆博物馆。为什么？
The plaque she unveiled celebrated young Peter Hall and Davis Hughes. young Peter Hall and Davis Hughes. In his book How Big Things Get Done, Bent Flubier describes what happened when Star architect Frank Geary was asked to come to Bill Bough to work on a building. Unlike the young unknown Utsun, Geary was 62 years old, battle hardened by some painful political fights over his buildings, and famous. Bill Barrow's officials showed him a beautiful old warehouse, and they asked him if he would consider renovating it to become a new Guggenheim museum. Why?
盖里问。你们想要达成什么目标？在悉尼，没有人真正提出过这些问题，更不用说回答它们了。但在毕尔巴鄂，他们知道自己想要什么。他们希望通过设计得到悉尼靠偶然性得到的东西。一个标志。毕尔巴鄂曾是南欧的底特律，是一座曾因去工业化而满目疮痍的伟大城市。
Ask Geary. What are you trying to achieve? In Sydney, nobody had really formulated those questions, let alone answered them. But in Bilbao, they knew what they wanted. They wanted to get by design, what Sydney had got by accident. An icon. Bilbao was the Detroit of southern Europe, a once great city ravaged by deindustrialization.
当地政府希望新博物馆能点燃城市的文艺复兴，把毕尔巴鄂推向世界地图，就像悉尼歌剧院把悉尼推向世界地图一样。“好吧，”盖里说。“如果是这样，忘了改造项目吧。你们得做悉尼做过的事，建造一些令人惊叹的崭新东西。你们得把它放在水滨，事实上，”盖里补充道。“我已经看好了一个地方。”
The local government wanted the new museum to spark an urban renaissance, to put Bilbao on the map just as Sydney Opera House had put Sydney on the map. "'Fine,' said Geary. "'In that case, forget the renovation project. "'You're going to have to do what Sydney did and build something breathtaking and new. "'You're going to have to put it on the waterfront and, in fact, added Geary. "'I've seen just the spot.
当盖里的毕尔巴鄂古根海姆博物馆最终开馆时，它取得了巨大成功，按时且预算内完成。根据弗利维伯格关于特大型项目的数据，这种事并不常发生。但它之所以能发生，是因为盖里从一个明确达成的计划开始，而且没有人急于开始动工。如今，每个人似乎都想要其中一座标志性建筑。毕竟，弗兰克·盖里让这一切看起来很简单，但悉尼歌剧院是第一个、最伟大也是最痛苦的。尽管经历了这一切，歌剧院依然是一件杰作。我有幸亲眼目睹它，在悉尼港漫步，欣赏所有角度，走上贝尼朗岬角裙楼宏伟的台阶。
When Geary's Guggenheim Bilbao was finally opened, it was a huge success, on time and under budget. According to Flubier's data on mega-projects, that sort of thing doesn't happen a lot. But the fact that it happened at all is because Geary started with a clearly agreed plan, and nobody rushed to start digging. These days, everybody seems to want one of those iconic buildings. Frank Geary made it look easy after all, but the Sydney Opera House was the first and the greatest and the most painful. In spite of everything, the Opera House is a masterpiece. I've been lucky enough to see it, to stroll around the Sydney Harbour, admiring all the angles, to stroll around the Sydney Harbour admiring all the angles, to walk up the grand steps of the podium on Benelong Point.
我甚至还在那个舞台上表演过。它太令人惊叹了。这一切都是。任何相机都无法展现它的全貌。在整个 20 世纪，只有帝国大厦堪与作为城市象征相媲美。悉尼歌剧院就像埃菲尔铁塔或金字塔。它已经多次回报了这座城市居民对它的付出。所以你可能会想，谁在乎它迟到了，谁在乎它花了多少钱，这一切最终都是值得的。但本特·弗利维伯格并不同意。建造歌剧院的过程是一场彻底的惨败，而那场惨败所付出的代价是无法用延误或金钱来衡量的。
I've even performed on the stage. It's breathtaking. All of it. No camera can do it justice. In the entire 20th century, only the Empire State Building comes close to serving as an icon of a city. The Sydney Opera House is like the Eiffel Tower or the Pyramids. It's repaid its debt to the citizens of the city many times over. So you might think, who cares that it was late, who cares what it cost, it was all worth it in the end. But Bent Flubier disagrees. The process of building the
代价从约恩·乌松的声誉开始。乌松被告知，由于他辞职了，他将永远不会在丹麦获得政府项目。他在夏威夷教了一段时间书，并为朋友的建筑事务所匿名设计了一些建筑。他确实赢得了在科威特设计大型项目的委托，但在 1991 年，萨达姆·侯赛因的军队烧毁了它。在哥本哈根的一个郊区，他建造了一座简朴的教堂。
Opera House was a fiasco, and that fiasco had a cost that you can't measure in delays or in dollars. The cost starts with Yorne Utson's reputation. Utson was told that because he had resigned, he'd never get a government project in Denmark. He taught for a while in Hawaii and anonymously designed some buildings for a friend's architecture practice. He did win a commission to design something big in Q8, but Saddam Hussein's army set fire to that in 1991. In a Copenhagen suburb, he built a humble church.
它从外面看并不起眼，但在内部，有一个华丽的天花板，看起来像一叠叠分开的布料，露出天堂的光芒。显然，他在歌剧院内部的设计中也怀有类似的想法，但没有人愿意再给他一次机会，在应得的舞台上展现他的天才。悉尼歌剧院的代价是什么？就是约恩·乌松再也不被允许设计的那些其他建筑。最终，建筑界觉醒了，开始向他倾泻奖项，通常带着遗憾地承认乌松除了歌剧院之外没有建造太多东西，但要改变这一点已经太迟了。当他赢得建筑界的诺贝尔奖——普利兹克奖时，他已经 85 岁高龄了。
It's unprepossessing on the outside, but on the inside there's a gorgeous ceiling that looks like folds of cloth, parting to reveal the light of heaven. Apparently, it had something similar in mind for the interior of the opera house, but nobody wanted to give him another chance to display his genius on the stage it deserved. The price of the Sydney Opera House? It was all those other buildings that Yorne Utsen was never allowed to design. Eventually, the architecture profession woke up and began showering prizes on him, often acknowledging regretfully that Utson
歌剧院本身也开始对这场争议以及那块甚至没有提到乌松名字的无品味牌匾感到尴尬。在 20 世纪 90 年代，他们试图修复关系，以他的名字命名了一个房间，并请他协助设计一个新的侧楼。尽管如此，他还是没有来。他派他的儿子去发表演讲，解释说他年迈的父亲……“生活在歌剧院里，呼吸着歌剧院的空气，作为它的创造者，他只需要闭上眼睛就能看到它。”其中一个对这种求和姿态冷嘲热讽的人是戴维斯·休斯，他像乌松一样已经是个老人了。他打电话给歌剧院管理团队的主席，滔滔不绝地讲了 45 分钟，反对让乌松对任何事情发表意见的想法。
hadn't built much besides the opera house, but it was too late to change that. When he won architecture's Nobel Prize, the Pritzker, he was 85 years old. The Opera House itself had started to become embarrassed by the controversy, and that graceless plaque that didn't even mention Utson's name. In the 1990s, they attempted a reproachement, naming a room in his honour, and asking him to help design
“我帮了乌松一个忙，”他说，“我结束了他的痛苦，就像安乐死一只狗一样。”在乌松生命的晚期，一位名叫约翰·帕蒂的英国建筑师去纽约看望了他，他晚年的大部分时间都在那里度过。这算是一次朝圣，去见一位真正的建筑巨匠。乌松当然设计了自己的家，帕蒂将其描述为……“一种没有眩光的寂静，仿佛把我带到了另一个世界。”他们谈论了这样那样的事情。这位老人偶尔流露出对歌剧院风波的痛苦，但这都是很久以前的事了。他说，乌松从未回过悉尼。他设计了
a new wing. Still, he didn't come. He sent his son to give a speech, explaining that his elderly father... "...lives and breathes the opera house, and as its creator, he just has to close his eyes to see it. One person who sneered at the peacemaking was Davis Hughes, an old man like Utzen himself. He phoned the chairman of the Opera House management team and ran for 45 minutes about the very idea of asking Uttsun his opinion on anything.
20 世纪最美丽的建筑，却从未亲眼见过它。感觉到乌松的心有一部分留在了悉尼，帕蒂提出帮助这位老人重返故地。乌松的妻子把帕蒂拉到一边。这不可能，她说。这会要了他的命。她指的是艰难的旅程吗？还是指那些回忆？本集的重要资料来源包括海伦·皮特的《房子》和彼得·默里的《悉尼歌剧院传奇》。如果你对本特·弗利维伯格和特大型项目感兴趣，我有一个关于 V2 火箭计划的三集系列节目。
I did Utsun a favour, he said, I put him out of his misery like you put down a dog. Late in Utsun's life, a British architect named John Party, went to visit him in New Yorker, where he'd spent most of his later years. It was a kind of pilgrimage to meet one of the true greats of architecture. Utsun had designed the home, of course, and party described it as... Glare-free hush that seemed to transport me to another world. They talked about this and that. The old man expressed the occasional pain at the Opera House of Fair, but this was all a long time ago. He said, Utsun had never been back to Sydney. He designed the
我帮了乌松一个忙，他说，我给了他个痛快，就像安乐死一只狗那样。在乌松晚年的时候，一位名叫约翰·帕蒂的英国建筑师去纽约拜访了他，他在纽约度过了晚年的大部分时间。这有点像是一场朝圣，去见一位真正的建筑巨匠。当然，这座住宅是乌松设计的，帕蒂将其形容为……“一种没有眩光的宁静，仿佛把我带到了另一个世界。”他们闲聊了一些事情。这位老人偶尔会对歌剧院的风波表达出一丝痛苦，但这一切都是很久以前的事了。他说，乌松再也没有回过悉尼。他设计了
most beautiful building of the 20th century, and had never seen it. Sensing that Utsun had left some part of his heart in Sydney, party offered to help the old man travel back. Utsun's wife pulled party aside. That wasn't possible, she said. It would kill him. Did she mean the arduous journey? Or did she mean the memories? Important sources for this episode were The House by Helen Pitt and The Saga of Sydney Opera House by Peter Murray. If you're interested in Bent Flubier and Mega Project, I have a three-part series on the V2 Rocket Program.
20世纪最美丽的建筑，却从未亲眼见过它。感觉到乌松在悉尼留下了他的一部分心血，帕蒂主动提出帮助这位老人重返悉尼。乌松的太太把帕蒂拉到一边。这不可能，她说。这会要了他的命。她是说旅途劳顿吗？还是指那些回忆？本集的重要参考资料包括海伦·皮特的《住宅》和彼得·默里的《悉尼歌剧院传奇》。如果你对贝恩特·弗卢比尔和大型项目感兴趣，我有一个关于V2火箭计划的三集系列节目。
It's available to subscribers on Pushkin Plus. For a full list of our sources, please see the show notes at timhalford.com Corsionry Tales is written by me Tim Halford with Andrew Wright It's produced by Alice Finds with support from Edith Husslo The sound design and original music is the work of Pascal Wise Sarah Nicks edited the scripts Corsionry Tales features the voice talents of Rufus Wright, Melanie Gushridge, Ben Crow, Stella Halford and Gemma Saunders.
Pushkin Plus 订阅用户可收听。有关我们资料来源的完整列表，请查看 timhalford.com 上的节目说明。本节目由我蒂姆·哈尔福德与安德鲁·赖特共同撰写，由爱丽丝·芬兹制作，埃迪·胡斯洛提供支持。声音设计和原创音乐由帕斯卡尔·怀斯完成，萨拉·尼克斯负责编辑剧本。本节目配音演员包括鲁福斯·怀特、梅兰尼·古什里奇、本·克劳、斯特拉·哈尔福德和杰玛·桑德斯。
The show wouldn't have been possible without the work of Jacob Weisberg, Ryan Dilly, Greta Cohn, Lytel Malard, John Schnarrs, Carly McGleory and Eric Sandler. Corsinary Tales has a production of Pushkin Industries. It was recorded in Wardle Studios in London by Tom Erie. If you like the show, please remember to share, rate and review. Go on, you know it helps us. And if you want to hear the show add free, sign up for Pushkin Plus on the show page in Apple podcasts or at's nothing I can do for you. I can't help you. You need to have your head examined. Subscribe now wherever you get your podcasts. We'll have a new 99PI from us next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本节目的制作离不开雅各布·韦斯伯格、瑞安·迪利、格丽塔·科恩、莱特尔·马拉德、约翰·施纳尔斯、卡莉·麦格罗里和埃里克·桑德林的辛勤工作。本节目由 Pushkin Industries 制作。由汤姆·埃里在伦敦沃德尔工作室录制。如果您喜欢本节目，请记得分享、评分和评论。去吧，你知道这会对我们有帮助。如果您想收听无广告版节目，请在 Apple Podcasts 的节目页面或通过以下方式订阅 Pushkin Plus... 我无能为力。我帮不了你。你得去检查一下脑子。现在就在您获取播客的地方订阅。我们下周将推出全新的 99PI。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。